I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey.
We were on The Office together and we're best friends.
And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you.
Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews
behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories.
We're the Office Lady 6.0.
Hi there.
Yay.
我是珍娜·费舍尔，我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》，并且是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来终极的《办公室》爱好者播客。每周，我们将通过独家采访、幕后细节和许多闺蜜故事，更深入地探索《办公室》的世界。我们是“办公室女士”6.0版。大家好。耶。
What's up?
We got energy today.
We do.
Is it because we're starting a little bit later?
I've had lunch.
I've had several.
ice teas. Yeah, I've had breakfast and lunch now. Yeah. We usually record in the mornings.
I know. Mm. Fuller tank after lunch. I think so. You guys, we're giving you the play by play.
怎么了？我们今天很有活力。确实。是因为我们开始得稍微晚了一点吗？我已经吃过午饭了。我已经吃好几顿了。冰茶。对，我现在吃过早午餐了。对。我们通常在早上录音。我知道。嗯。午饭后电量更充足了。我也这么觉得。各位，我们在向你们实况转播呢。
We have a super fun episode today. I know we say that all the time, but this is something that is so close to
my heart. You guys, you know, I love the candy bag alts. We fell in love with them during our
rewatch of the office. And today we are going to dig in deep to some can you.
candy bags. Yes. And if you've listened to the podcast for a while, you know what we're talking
about when we say the office candy bag. But just in case, we have some new folks listening today,
quick recap. So on the set of the office, the writers used to write us extra dialogue that would
serve as like alternate jokes in a scene or maybe an alternate take on a talking head. Exactly. And then
And sometimes they would write us multiple pages of alts.
我们今天有一集超级有趣的节目。我知道我们老是这么说，但这对我来说意义非凡。各位，你们知道的，我喜欢糖果袋备选台词。我们在重温《办公室》时爱上了它们。今天我们要深入探讨一些“糖果袋”。是的。如果你听这个播客有一段时间了，当你听到“办公室糖果袋”时，你就知道我们在说什么。但以防万一，今天有一些新听众，我们快速回顾一下。在《办公室》的片场，编剧们经常会给我们写一些额外的台词，作为某个场景中的备选笑话，或者可能是对某个单人访谈镜头的另一种演绎。没错。然后有时候他们会给我们写好几页的备选项。
And Greg was worried that we would get grumpy about having to learn all these extra lines.
So he came up with this sort of phrase called candy bag because his theory was, well, basically,
who's ever sad about getting a bag of candy?
Isn't that such a way that one would manipulate Michael Scott specifically?
Yes.
Greg said that he sort of thought of us as like his children.
Yeah.
And he was like, what would I say to my kids to motivate them?
格雷格担心我们会因为必须学习所有这些额外的台词而发脾气。所以他想出了这样一个叫做“糖果袋”的词，因为他的理论是，嗯，基本上，谁会因为得到一袋糖果而不高兴呢？这难道不是操纵迈克尔·斯科特本人的绝妙方式吗？是的。格雷格说他有点把我们当成他的孩子。没错。他说，我对我的孩子们会说些什么来激励他们呢？
Ooh, candy.
Well, what we've learned over the years of rewatching the office for this podcast is that the candy bag alts are full of wonderful treasures.
Just hilarious moments written for each of our characters.
Angela, you started digging into them, and they're always so fun.
We got a couple letters.
First from Marcus R in Grand Rapids, Michigan, who said,
Hi, hi, ladies, I love the podcast.
I've been listening since the beginning.
哦，糖果。嗯，这些年来我们为这个播客重温《办公室》时所了解到的是，糖果袋备选台词充满了奇妙的宝藏。为我们的每一个角色量身定制的爆笑时刻。安吉拉，你开始深入挖掘它们了，而且总是那么有趣。我们收到了几封信。首先来自密歇根州大急流城的马库斯·R，他说，嗨，女士们，我喜欢这个播客。我从一开始就一直在听。
I know you like to hear how people listen, and I listen when I walk my dog Luke in the evenings.
Luke. Oh my gosh. I know. I love animals with real human names. People names. Yes. I know. Marcus doesn't say
what kind of dog Luke is, but I'm imagining a golden retriever. Oh, okay. I don't know. Maybe write us back,
Marcus, tell us if we're right. Yeah. But Marcus goes on to say, I love when Angela shares from the candy bag.
I can't believe how they could write so many different versions of the same scene or talking head.
they are also freaking funny.
And Sarah P from Flagstaff, Arizona said,
I've been listening to the second drinks,
我知道你们喜欢听人们是怎么收听的，我是在晚上遛狗卢克的时候听的。卢克。哦，天哪。我知道。我喜欢有人类真名动物。人类的名字。是的。我知道。马库斯没有说卢克是什么品种的狗，但我脑海里想象的是一只金毛寻猎者。哦，好吧。我不知道。也许你可以回信给我们，马库斯，告诉我们我们猜得对不对。是的。但马库斯接着说，我喜欢安吉拉分享糖果袋里的内容。我真不敢相信他们怎么能为同一个场景或单人访谈写出这么多不同版本的台词。它们也太搞笑了吧。来自亚利桑那州弗拉格斯塔夫的萨拉·P说，我一直在听第二杯，
and I love every time Angela shares from the candy bag.
Well, Sarah and Marcus, thank you,
because I love it too.
And like you said, it's just treasure after treasure.
So we thought it might be fun to do an episode
where we share candy bag alts for each character of the office.
And we figured what better way to start than with Michael Scott?
Holy moly, people.
我喜欢安吉拉分享糖果袋内容的每一次。好吧，萨拉和马库斯，谢谢你们，因为我也很喜欢。就像你们说的，这简直是宝藏接连不断。所以我们觉得做一集节目，分享《办公室》每个角色的糖果袋备选台词，一定很有趣。我们觉得还有什么比从迈克尔·斯科特开始更好的呢？天哪，伙计们。
We have uncovered some amazing Michael moments.
We can't wait to share them with you.
But first, let's start with our chit chat from Carolyn G in Orange County, California.
Hi, ladies.
I'm also a fan of Amy Poller's podcast Good Hang,
and she often brings up her Eniogram number,
which is that personality test from a scale from one to nine,
and she compares hers with her guests.
我们挖掘到了一些惊艳的迈克尔时刻。我们迫不及待地想与你们分享。但首先，让我们从加利福尼亚州橙县的卡罗琳·G的闲聊开始。嗨，女士们。我也是艾米·波勒的播客《美好闲逛》的粉丝，她经常提到她的九型人格号码，那是从一到九的性格测试，她会把自己的号码和嘉宾的进行比较。
And I was wondering if you ladies have ever taken that test,
and if you think your number matches you well or not.
I'm so curious to hear. Thanks. Thanks, Carolyn. I know. I was really curious about this because I'm also a fan of Amy's podcast and I've heard her talk about it and I didn't know what it was. I've known what it is for a while. I did not ever take the test because I don't know what this says about me. Maybe this is fitting within my aneogram. But I don't love things that sort of put me in a
label.
Label.
Yeah.
You know, I don't like psychics telling me my future because I believe in free will.
And like, I don't believe that like my life was like set out, like that it was only ever going to be one way.
我想知道你们女士是否做过这个测试，你们觉得你们的号码和你们相配吗？我很想听听看。谢谢。谢谢，卡罗琳。我知道。我对这个真的很好奇，因为我也是艾米播客的粉丝，我听她说过，但我不知道那是什么。我早就知道那是什么了。我从来没有做过这个测试，因为我不知道这说明了什么关于我的事。也许这很符合我的九型人格。但我不太喜欢那种给我贴标签的东西。标签。对。你知道的，我不喜欢算命先生告诉我未来，因为我相信自由意志。而且，我不相信我的生活是命中注定的，就像它注定只有一种方式一样。
Like I believe we can choose our destiny.
And so I sort of feel that way.
But for you, Carolyn, I took this test.
Wow.
And I sent it to you, Angie.
You did.
Look what you did for love of the podcast community lady.
I love it.
就像我相信我们可以选择自己的命运一样。所以我基本上是这种感觉。但是为了你，卡罗琳，我做了这个测试。哇。我把它发给你了，安吉。你确实发了。瞧瞧你为了播客社区的爱做了什么，女士。我太喜欢了。
I know.
I also took the test.
Unlike you.
I didn't know about it. Two, I wasn't nervous about it. And three, whatever they say, I'm like,
eh, whatever. I'm so curious what you are. I don't know what the nine are. I just know what I am now.
Okay. I don't know what the nine are either, but I guess Amy is an eight. I looked that up.
Oh. So I guess what an eight is called is the Challenger. Okay. And I don't know very much about
this guys. So I guess a Challenger energy is described as someone who,
我知道。我也做了这个测试。不像你。我之前不知道它。第二，我对此并不紧张。第三，不管他们怎么说，我都觉得，呃，随便啦。我很好奇你是什么。我不知道那九种是什么。我只知道我现在是什么。好吧。我也不知道那九种是什么，但我猜艾米是八号。我查过了。哦。所以我想八号被称为“挑战者”。好吧。大家对这个了解不多，所以我猜挑战者的能量被描述为这样的人：
charges the room, gets into action immediately. They have a desire to lead and manage power effectively,
things like that. Well, the test that we took gave me like a percentage for each one of the nine
types. Yeah. I have one that I was 95%. Me too. Like my number one was like a strong number one.
Same. Incidentally, I am number one. I am a type one. What is that? The reformer. The
reformer.
Ooh.
I focus on ethics, order, precision, and the inner critic.
Oh.
充满活力地冲进房间，立即采取行动。他们有领导和有效管理权力的渴望，诸如此类。好吧，我们做的测试给出了九种类型中每一种的百分比。对。我有一个高达95%的。我也是。就像我的第一名是一个非常强烈的名次。一样。顺便说一下，我是第一号。我是一个一型。那是什么？改革者。改革者。哦。我关注伦理、秩序、精确度和内在批判者。哦。
It was kind of accurate.
It was kind of bumming me out how accurate was.
Well, for all of my not wanting to be painted with one brush.
My 95% category is type 2, the helper.
Wow.
And I focus on generosity, the need to be needed.
I don't know if that's great.
And the fear of being unlovable, I don't think that's me.
这还挺准的。它准确得让我有点沮丧。好吧，既然我这么不想被一概而论。我的95%类别是二型，助人者。哇。我关注慷慨、被需要的需求。我不知道这是否很好。以及不讨人喜欢的恐惧，我觉得那不是我。
I don't think you have a.
fear of being unlovable. I think you know how lovable you are. Oh, stop. No, you have, I think you know that
you are good at loving people and being loved. I like, I like helping people I do. Yeah. Maybe there's,
there is something there that I like to be of service and needed. My second highest score, though,
was the challenger. Oh, same as Amy Polar. I charge into a room. Yeah. And want to help you
aggressively. You know, it's interesting, my helper score is very low, the helper.
52% the helper. My second was the achiever. So I'm a reformer and an achiever, I guess.
Well, my the reformer score is 80%. Oh, you're there. You're with me. What's your lowest score?
我觉得你没有不讨人喜欢的恐惧。我觉得你知道自己有多讨人喜欢。哦，得了吧。不，你有，我觉得你知道你善于去爱别人并且被爱。我喜欢，我喜欢帮助别人，我确实喜欢。是的。也许这其中有些东西，我确实喜欢为他人服务并被需要。不过我的第二高分是挑战者。哦，和艾米·波勒一样。我冲进房间。对。并且想要积极地帮助你。你知道，有趣的是，我的助人者得分很低，助人者。52%是助人者。我的第二高分是成就者。所以我想我是一个改革者和一个成就者。好吧，我的改革者得分是80%。哦，你在那儿。你和我一样。你最低的得分是什么？
My lowest was the peacemaker. I don't know what that means. My peacemaker's right in the middle.
it's 83.
My lowest was, this makes me sound like such a basic bitch.
My lowest score was the individualist.
I just want to go with the flow.
You know, I remember the questions that I think might have, like, pertained to being
a person who is the peacemaker, you know, because it's all like strongly agree, agree,
neutral, disagree, strongly disagree.
我最低的是和平缔造者。我不知道那意味着什么。我的和平缔造者刚好在中间。是83。我最低的是，这让我听起来像个基本款碧池。我最低的得分是个体主义者。我只是想随波逐流。你知道，我记得那些我认为可能与成为和平缔造者有关的问题，你知道的，因为全都是强力赞同、赞同、中立、反对、强烈反对。
And I feel like peacemaker questions were things like it's very,
hard for me when people are in conflict. It's not hard for me. I don't feel the need to make peace.
I think we can spend time in a messy confrontational space where we're figuring things out.
It's okay. Yeah, I don't know. I have to say I was not a fan of the test. I don't like tests
that are like multiple choice. How would you have done the test differently? I don't know. This is not
my job to create the test, but I'm just saying I wasn't a fan. I don't. I don't.
Like, strongly agree, agree, neutral, disagree, strongly disagree.
Did you strongly agree or strongly disagree to things?
我觉得和平缔造者的问题类似于，当人们处于冲突中时，这对我很艰难。这对我并不艰难。我觉得没有必要去求和。我觉得我们可以花时间在一个混乱的对抗空间里，在那里我们把事情弄清楚。这没关系。是的，我不知道。我得说我不是这个测试的粉丝。我不喜欢多选题这种测试。你觉得这个测试应该怎么做才对？我不知道。创建测试不是我的工作，但我只是说我不是它的粉丝。我不。我不。喜欢强力赞同、赞同、中立、反对、强烈反对。你对事情是强烈赞同还是强烈反对？
Sometimes.
Yeah, same.
Same.
I strongly agreed to a lot of stuff.
Well, you're a reformer.
Yeah.
It's true, I guess.
Well, it was very interesting.
有时是。是的，一样。一样。我对很多事情都强烈赞同。好吧，你是个改革者。是的。我想确实如此。好吧，这真的很有趣。
Sam, have you taken this test?
No, I haven't.
I'm going to take it right now.
Oh, will you tell us at the end what your score is?
Okay.
Do you want us to send it to you, the one that we took?
Yes, I would.
It costs $1.50 to get your results.
萨姆，你做过这个测试吗？不，我没有。我现在就要做。哦，你能在最后告诉我们你的得分是多少吗？好的。你想让我们把我们做过的那个发给你吗？是的，我会的。获取测试结果需要1.50美元。
I'm more than willing to pay.
I'm pretty sure now I'm going to be on an email list, too.
Oh, yeah, your information's sold for sure.
Yeah.
Well, Carolyn, there you go.
If I ever go on Good Hang, I'll know my score.
That's good, right?
Oh, yeah.
我很乐意付钱。我挺确信现在我也会被列入某个电子邮件列表了。哦，是的，你的信息绝对被卖了。是的。好吧，卡罗琳，给你。如果我以后去上《美好闲逛》，我就会知道我的得分了。这挺好吧，对吧？哦，是的。
And I want to ask her about being the challenger.
Yeah, you share that.
I do.
That's number two on my list.
I know.
All right.
Well, everyone, why?
don't we take a break? And when we come back, buckle in because it's Michael Scott Candybag.
我想问问她关于当挑战者的事。对，你分享一下那个。我知道。那是我的第二名。好吧。那么，各位，我们为什么不休息一下呢？当我们回来时，系好安全带，因为接下来是迈克尔·斯科特的糖果袋。
Hey there, it's Jill Schlesinger. I'm launching a new show. It's called Money Moves, and
your money is going to move. We're going to help you make better financial decisions.
We're going to call out the BS you're finding all over social media. We're going to give you
actionable guidance to make your financial life clearer, less stressful. We're going to answer
your financial questions and take the mystery out of your financial life. Follow and, and
listen to Money Moves with Jill Schlesinger, wherever you get your podcast.
We are back.
And to kick things off, I thought we needed a little candy.
大家好，我是吉尔·施莱辛格。我将推出一个新节目。它叫《金钱流向》，你的金钱将会流动。我们将帮助你做出更好的财务决策。我们将痛斥你在社交媒体上到处都能看到的胡言乱语。我们将为你提供可操作的指导，让你的财务生活更清晰、压力更小。我们将解答你的财务问题，揭开你财务生活的神秘面纱。在你能收听播客的任何地方，关注并收听吉尔·施莱辛格的《金钱流向》。我们回来了。为了开个好头，我觉得我们需要一点糖果。
Like real life candy?
Real candy.
What did you bring?
Well, I wanted to know, did Michael Scott have a favorite candy?
Is it like the Whatchamacallit or something?
Well, that's not his favorite.
And I couldn't find anything really specifically.
He loves sweets.
像现实生活中的糖果？真正的糖果。你带来了什么？好吧，我想知道，迈克尔·斯科特有最喜欢的糖果吗？是像“叫什么名字”巧克力糖之类的吗？好吧，那不是他最喜欢的。而且我找不到任何非常具体的东西。他喜欢甜食。
We know that.
But in the meeting, season six,
episode two, he does try to share his love of jelly beans with Jim. So I brought jelly beans.
Oh, great. There you go. Can have some jelly beans. Okay. Do you like jelly beans?
I do. It's not to like. I know. I like them, too. I love jelly beans. I even love some funky
flavors. Oh, so do you like a jelly belly that has like a real flavor? Or do you like the ones that I
brought, these are just like your typical like Brock's tiny jelly beans? Like the
the kind you have at Easter.
我们都知道这一点。但在第六季第二集的会议中，他确实试图与吉姆分享他对果冻豆的喜爱。所以我带来了果冻豆。哦，太棒了。给你。吃点果冻豆。好的。你喜欢果冻豆吗？我喜欢。这有什么不喜欢呢。我知道。我也喜欢。我喜欢果冻豆。我甚至喜欢一些奇怪的味道。哦，所以你喜欢那种有真实风味的吉利豆吗？还是你喜欢我带来的这种，这些只是像你平常吃的布洛克微型果冻豆？就像你在复活节吃的那种？
Guess where mine are from?
Easter.
Yeah.
The outside was a little crunchy.
Well, I want them out of my house.
You were?
It's plain cleaning.
I was like talking to you and you were telling me all the different stuff you were cleaning out.
猜猜我的来自哪里？复活节。是的。外皮有点脆。好吧，我想把它们清理出我的房子。你在？这是大扫除。我当时在跟你说话，你正在告诉我你正在清理的各种杂物。
So I guess you just got rid of your jelly beans.
Well, I'm lucky.
Michael Scott liked them.
So it worked out.
You are.
So listen, I was also really curious when we said we were going to dig into these.
And I wanted to get into the context of like, how did the candy bags work
from a production standpoint.
所以我想你只是把你的果冻豆扔了。好吧，我很幸运。迈克尔·斯科特喜欢它们。所以结果挺好。确实如此。所以听着，当我们要深入研究这些东西时，我也真的很好奇。我想从制作的角度了解一下糖果袋是如何运作的背景。
You know, like, how would they decide which version of a scene or a talking head to use?
So we reached out to Dave Rogers to ask him, and we said when he would do his assembly,
when he would do his editor's pass, would he use the scripted version or did he have license
to put in the candy bag one?
Like, how were these things organized?
How did it all work?
This is very much your producer brain, wanting to.
figure it out, which I love about you.
你知道，比如，他们会如何决定使用场景或单人访谈的哪个版本？所以我们联系了戴夫·罗杰斯来问他，我们说当他做粗剪时，当他做剪辑师的初剪时，他会使用剧本版本还是有权放入糖果袋版本？比如，这些东西是怎么组织的？这一切是怎么运作的？这非常符合你身为制作人的大脑，想要把它弄清楚，我太爱你的这一点了。
Well, here's what Dave said.
By the way, Dave always gets back to us right away.
I know.
I know I say it a gazillion times, but I love him.
He said, we would get all of the takes of a talking head, and the assistant editors would
usually label them as Alt A, Alt B, etc.
And the editors would watch them all and put into the assembly whatever take they liked the best.
It did not matter if it was the scripted line or a must shoot alt or a candy bag alt.
好吧，戴夫是这么说的。顺便说一句，戴夫总是立刻回复我们。我知道。我知道我说过无数次了，但我太爱他了。他说，我们会得到单人访谈的所有拍摄版本，助理剪辑师通常会将它们标为备选A、备选B等。剪辑师会观看所有这些版本，并将他们最喜欢的版本放入粗剪中。无论是剧本台词、必拍备选台词还是糖果袋备选台词，都没关系。
Same for scenes in the show.
It didn't matter to the editors if a line was officially scripted or if there was a new joke or dialogue that a writer pitched on set or an actor improvised.
Once a scene was filmed and ready to edit, whatever was the funniest and best served the show and that made it into the cut.
Very interesting. So the editors really had a lot of agency to go through that footage and kind of pick what they thought worked best.
Yeah. Remember, Jenna, when you and I co-presented at the editors awards,
And I remember several people as they got up and they were talking about the different awards they got.
A theme was that a writer writes the script, but the second storyteller is the editor.
And I thought that was really powerful.
剧集中的场景也是如此。对于剪辑师来说，一句台词是官方剧本里的，还是编剧在片场临时想出的新笑话或对话，亦或是演员即兴发挥的，这都无关紧要。一旦一个场景拍摄完成并准备剪辑，无论哪个最搞笑、最能为剧集服务，就会进入最终剪辑版。非常有趣。所以剪辑师确实有很大的自主权来浏览这些素材，并挑选出他们认为效果最好的部分。是的，还记得吗，珍娜，当我和你一起在剪辑师大奖上颁奖时，我还记得有几个人上台谈论他们获得的各种奖项时。一个共同的主题是，编剧写了剧本，但第二个讲故事的人是剪辑师。我觉得这真的很有力量。
Yeah.
I mean, when Lee made his movie, the giant mechanical man, we shot the scenes in a certain order.
But then when he went in with his editor, they rearranged stuff.
That's crazy to me.
Me too.
Yeah.
Yeah, they moved certain things up, or it was like, we put all the comedy in a row, maybe we want to break it up with something more sentimental or something more moving.
是的。是的。我的意思是，当李制作他的电影《机械巨人》时，我们按特定的顺序拍摄了场景。但后来当他和他的剪辑师进去时，他们重新排列了东西。这对我来说太疯狂了。对我也一样。是的。是的，他们把某些事情提前了，或者就像，我们把所有的喜剧连在一起，也许我们想用一些更感伤或更感人的东西来打破它。
And I was just, I was fascinated because that was the first time that I had been attached to a project from a producerial standpoint where I really saw stuff from like page to screen.
And it changed a lot in editing.
Yeah.
Editors are amazing.
Full stop.
Well, let's really dig in now to these Michael Scott Candy Bag Alts.
Jenna, I did not tell you which episodes I dug into.
My only hint to you was that I took things from our early seasons.
而且我当时，我非常着迷，因为那是我第一次从制作人的角度参与到一个项目中，我真正看到了从剧本到银幕的过程。它在剪辑中改变了很多。是的。剪辑师太棒了。句号。好吧，现在让我们真正深入探讨这些迈克尔·斯科特的糖果袋备选台词。珍娜，我没有告诉你我深入研究了哪些集。我对你唯一的提示是我取材于我们的早期剧季。
And are you ready for something pretty amazing from season two?
What?
I can't even believe I found this because we did such a comprehensive breakdown of this particular episode with Greg Daniels.
Try to guess the episode, Boos Cruz?
Yes.
How?
Is there anything left for discussion?
about Boos Cruz, but I'm telling you, the candy bags are amazing. So remember the scene in
你准备好听听来自第二季的一些相当惊艳的内容了吗？什么？我简直不敢相信我找到了这个，因为我们和格雷格·丹尼尔斯对这一集进行了非常全面的剖析。猜猜是哪集，《游船派对》？对。怎么猜到的？关于《游船派对》，还有什么可讨论的吗？但我告诉你，糖果袋太惊艳了。所以还记得那个场景吗？
Boos Cruz at the beginning of the episode when everyone's in the conference room and Michael is sharing
that they're going to go on this boat as part of his quote, leadership exercises. Yes. And he has a
talking head about being a motivational speaker. I want to play for you what made it into the episode.
And then I want you to know that there were seven candy bag alts for this one talking
head. They're hilarious. I'm going to pick four favorites to share with you, but let's hear
the one that made it in the episode first. I am a great motivational speaker. I attended a Tony
Robbins event by the airport last year, and it wasn't the actual course. You have to pay for
the actual course. But it talked about the actual course. And I've incorporated a lot of his
在《游船派对》集首，当每个人都在会议室里，迈克尔宣布他们将作为他所谓的“领导力练习”的一部分去坐这艘船时。是的。他有一个关于做励志演讲者的单人访谈。我想放给你们听听最终进入正片的那段。然后我想让你们知道，这一个单人访谈有七个糖果袋备选台词。它们太爆笑了。我挑了四个最喜欢的与你们分享，但让我们先听听进入正片的那段。我是一个伟大的励志演讲者。我去年在机场附近参加了一个托尼·罗宾斯活动，那不是真正的课程。你必须为真正的课程付钱。但它谈到了真正的课程。我把他的许多
ideas into my own course.
So, yeah, there were seven candy bag alts for this.
I just want to share with you some of my favorites.
Okay.
Here's one.
Michael would have said, I have incorporated many of his ideas.
Michael, give us all the answers.
No, I will not do that.
想法融入到了我自己的课程中。所以，是的，对此有七个糖果袋备选台词。我只想和你们分享一些我最喜欢的。好的。这是其中一个。迈克尔本会说，我融入了他的许多想法。迈克尔，给我们所有的答案吧。不，我不会那样做。
I will lead you to the answers and give you some of the answers.
You will get the rest of the answers when you pay for my course.
That's ridiculous.
And then he said, here's another alt.
Tony Robbins is international.
I am local and national.
So more accessibility to people, thus better at motivating.
I get so happy when I motivate someone and so sad when I do the opposite,
我会引导你们找到答案，并给你们一部分答案。当你为我的课程付费时，你就会得到其余的答案。这太荒谬了。然后他说，这里还有另一个备选项。托尼·罗宾斯是国际化的。我是本地和全国性的。所以对人们来说更具可及性，因此更擅长激励。当我激励某人时我感到非常高兴，而当我做相反的事情时我感到非常难过，
which is why I stopped doing that.
So wait, he stopped motivating people?
For fear of doing the opposite?
Of making them sad?
Anyway, cracked me up.
All right, here's another one.
Tony Robbins is about reaching for the stars.
My employees are never going to reach the stars.
这就是为什么我不再那样做了。所以等等，他不再激励人了？因为害怕做相反的事？让他们难过？不管怎样，把我笑死了。好吧，这里还有另一个。托尼·罗宾斯讲的是摘星。我的员工永远不会摘到星星。
and telling them they can is just mean.
What I can do is get them drunk and motivate them to just reach up, reach to the ceiling.
Okay, wait, I have two more.
When I motivationally speak, it's like a natural high for me.
I can see why people are addicted to crack because when I motivate, I want to motivate again,
like 15 minutes later.
What?
Michael.
告诉他们可以只是件刻薄的事。我能做的是把他们灌醉，激励他们只是往上够，够到天花板。好吧，等等，我还有两个。当我做励志演讲时，这就像是我的自然嗨。我能理解为什么人们会对瘾品上瘾，因为当我激励时，我想再次激励，就像15分钟后那样。什么？迈克尔。
All right, so that's a little bit of Michael Scott, Candybag Alts, from booze.
cruise cruise season two. And then I thought, what's happening in season three? Lady, almost like I spun a
will. I just did my cursor down my computer and I just landed on beach games. Ooh. Ooh. Are you ready?
This is like so fun. The Michael Scott Talking Head Alts for Beach Games were super stacked. I shared a little
bit in our second drink about talking heads that Phyllis and Meredith had because people had a lot of
feelings about this beach day. But I want to share the ones where Michael is really sort of trying
to figure out his legacy as he's leaving Dunder Mifflin to go to the corporate offices.
Here's the talking head that aired, and then I'm going to share a few that were in the candy bag
好吧，这就是来自第二季《游船派对》的一些迈克尔·斯科特糖果袋备选台词。然后我想，第三季发生了什么？女士，就像我转动了一个轮盘。我只是把光标移到电脑下方，然后就落在了《海滩游戏》上。哦。哦。准备好了吗？这太有趣了。《海滩游戏》中迈克尔·斯科特的单人访谈备选台词内容非常丰富。我在我们的第二杯节目中简短分享了菲利斯和梅雷迪思的单人访谈，因为人们对这个海滩日有很多感想。但我想分享迈克尔在离开邓德米弗林前往公司总部时，真正试图找出他的传奇所在的那些台词。以下是播出的单人访谈，然后我将分享糖果袋中的一些台词
alts. I want today to be a beautiful memory that the staff and I share after I have passed on
to New York. And if Toby is a part of it, then it'll suck.
Oh yeah, this is how he manages to like leave Toby behind, right?
Uh-huh.
But this is sort of the beginning of this runner about like what is his legacy, right?
And then they wrote a ton, a ton of alts.
And I want to share them with you.
Oh, amazing.
备选项。我希望今天能成为我和员工在我去世前往纽约之后共同分享的美好回忆。如果托比是其中的一部分，那就会糟透了。哦，是的，这就是他设法把托比抛在脑后的方式，对吧？嗯哼。但这有点像是关于他的传奇是什么的这个连环桥段的开始，对吧？然后他们写了大量的备选台词。我想和你们分享。哦，太棒了。
What do you remember from a movie?
The ending?
You know at the end of Pirates of the Caribbean when Johnny Depp goes, arg!
That's all I remember from that movie.
And it was my favorite movie too.
So through all the ups and downs,
the trials and Tribiani's.
When they remember Michael Scott and Scranton,
你从电影里记得什么？结局？你知道在《加勒比海盗》的结尾，约翰尼·德普说，呀！这就是我从那部电影里记住的全部。这也是我最喜欢的电影。所以经历了所有的起起落落，所有的苦难和特里比亚尼。当他们想起迈克尔·斯科特和斯克兰顿时，
they're going to remember, it was a day at the beach.
Argue.
Most of all, I love that he says trials and triviani.
Do you think he loved friends?
He must have loved friends.
Of course.
Of course Michael loved friends.
他们会记得，那是海滩上的一天。呀。最重要的是，我喜欢他说“苦难和特里比亚尼”。你觉得他喜欢《老友记》吗？他一定很喜欢《老友记》。当然。迈克尔当然喜欢《老友记》。当然。
Here's another one.
One of the best fortune cookies I ever got,
quote,
live so that your name will be written in hearts, not in stone.
And an all-time best,
quote, help, I am trapped in a fortune cookie factory.
That's what I want people to remember of the days I spent in Scranton, jokes, games, hugs.
Quote, working for Michael was like a day at the beach.
这里还有另一个。我收到的最好的幸运饼干之一，引述：“活出名声，让你的名字刻在心中，而不是石头上。”还有史上最佳，引述：“救命，我被困在幸运饼干工厂里了。”这就是我希望人们记住我在斯克兰顿度过的日子的内容，笑话、游戏、拥抱。引述：“为迈克尔工作就像是海滩上的一天。”
But if that doesn't sum up Michael Scott, what he wanted, his employees to remember were jokes, games, and hugs.
Yeah.
All right.
I have three more.
And then I promise I'll be done.
They were so good.
Here's another one from Michael.
What I'm working in my fancy new corporate office and I think of Scranton, I don't want to remember just Pam answering the phone or Stanley writing up purchase orders.
但如果这不能概括迈克尔·斯科特，他希望员工们记住的是笑话、游戏和拥抱。是的。好吧。我还有三个。然后我保证我就讲完了。它们太棒了。迈克尔的另一个。当我在这间豪华的新公司办公室工作，我想起斯克兰顿的时候，我不想只记得帕姆接电话或斯坦利写采购订单。
I want to remember them like they'll be today, having splash fights and digging castles in the sand, just playing like children, and maybe some of them in bikinis.
Oh, dear.
Okay, here's one more.
My favorite kind of sale is a twofer.
Pay full price for one thing, get another of the same thing for free.
What's better than a twofer?
A three-fer.
And that's what today is.
我想像他们今天这样记住他们，打水仗，在沙里挖城堡，就像小孩子一样玩耍，也许其中一些人还穿着比基尼。哦，天哪。好吧，还有一个。我最喜欢的一种促销是“买一赠一”。原价买一件，免费得到另一件同款。有什么比“买一赠一”更好？“买一赠三”。这就是今天的意义。
We're going to the beach, have a great time.
And in the meantime, I'm going to find my replacement.
And the staff is going to have a full day worth of memories that say,
Michael Scott is the best boss ever.
Three for the price of fun.
Three for the price of fun, lady.
Jokes, games, and hugs.
This is Michael Scott.
我们要去海滩，玩得开心。与此同时，我要寻找我的替代者。员工们将会度过充满回忆的一整天，他们会说，迈克尔·斯科特是有史以来最好的老板。乐趣的三倍价格。乐趣的三倍价格，女士。笑话、游戏和拥抱。这就是迈克尔·斯科特。
Last one. Okay, for real, last one. Michael would have said this. I have an interior motive for going to the beach. An interior motive? I can't decide who to recommend is my replacement. Not surprising, tall order. I'm going to test them all with carnival games until a hero emerges.
Anyway, those are some Michael Scott candy bag alts from booze crews and beach games. I thought you get a little season two, you get a little season three. How amazing.
were those? I mean, every single one of them is gold. I know. Truly. Trials and Tribionis. Come on. I can hear
like Steve doing them, too. I know. I'm sorry you guys had to put up with me reading them because I can
just hear Michael Scott's voice so clear in my head. But I mean, there's so many that I just now want to
commit to memory. Jokes, games and hugs, trials and tribunis. I have an interior motive.
I mean, those are all great. I know. The thing I was the most surprised about,
all those alts is that there wasn't more Toby bashing.
最后一个。好吧，说真的，最后一个。迈克尔会这么说。我去海滩有一个不可告人的动机。不可告人的动机？我无法决定推荐谁来接替我。毫不意外，这是一项艰巨的任务。我要用嘉年华游戏考验他们所有人，直到英雄出现。总之，这些是来自《游船派对》和《海滩游戏》的一些迈克尔·斯科特糖果袋备选台词。我想你们既听了第二季，也听了第三季。它们有多棒？我的意思是，每一个都是宝藏。我知道。真的。苦难和特里比亚尼。得了吧。我甚至能听到史蒂夫说这些台词的声音。我知道。很抱歉你们不得不忍受我朗读它们，因为我能在我脑海中非常清晰地听到迈克尔·斯科特的声音。但我的意思是，有太多台词我现在就想把它背下来。笑话、游戏和拥抱，苦难和特里比亚尼。我有一个不可告人的动机。我的意思是，这些都很棒。我知道。我最惊讶的是，所有这些备选台词里竟然没有更多的痛骂托比的内容。
Well, lady, I knew you were looking into early season candy bags.
So I decided to look into one of my favorite episodes, one of my just personal favorite
episodes, Dream Team.
Got it.
I was particularly curious if there were any alts from when Pam goes to Michael's condo and
he's making the French toast because I felt like I remembered shooting alternates for that.
And first of all, I want to share that the candy bag for Dream Team was 54 pages long.
That's nuts.
好吧，女士，我知道你在寻找早期剧季的糖果袋。所以我决定研究我最喜欢的剧集之一，我个人最喜欢的剧集之一，《梦之队》。明白了。我特别好奇，当帕姆去迈克尔的公寓，他在做法国吐司时，有没有什么备选台词，因为我觉得我记得为那一幕拍摄了备选项。首先，我想分享的是，《梦之队》的糖果袋长达54页。这太疯狂了。
Almost twice as long as the actual script.
Right.
Now, part of that is because what they'll do is they'll put the scripted talking head followed by then what the alts are.
Or they'll put the scene followed by the alts.
So you have the original one to reference.
but still, I mean, candy bags were thicker than our scripts.
So I'm going through, looking at these 54 pages, and I was right,
there were a bunch of extended alternate endings for the scene where Michael asked Pam how she wants her French toast.
几乎是实际剧本的两倍长。现在，部分原因是因为他们会把剧本中的单人访谈放在前面，接着是备选项。或者他们会把场景放在前面，然后是备选项。所以你可以参考原本的那一版。但即便如此，我的意思是，糖果袋比我们的剧本还要厚。所以我翻阅着这54页，我猜对了，迈克尔问帕姆想要什么样的法国吐司的那场戏，有一堆扩展的备选结局。
So first, let's listen to how the scene went down.
This looks great, Michael.
Thank you.
Would you like some French toast?
Yes, please.
What shape?
Square is fine?
All right.
所以首先，让我们听听那个场景是怎么演的。看起来真不错，迈克尔。谢谢。你想吃点法国吐司吗？好的，谢谢。什么形状的？正方形的就行？好的。
So that's it.
It's very simple.
Yeah.
But they had all these alternate endings that they wrote for the scene.
And I found this kind of fascinating because I thought that, like, this was such a good example of how even, like, the smallest moments, they were so dedicated to them being as funny as possible that they wrote alternates to that little French toast exchange.
Yeah.
Okay.
So here's an alternate.
就是这样。非常简单。是的。但他们为这个场景写了所有这些备选结局。我觉得这挺迷人的，因为我认为，这真是一个很好的例子，说明即使是像这样最小的时刻，他们也如此致力于让它们尽可能搞笑，以至于他们为那个小小的法国吐司对话写了备选项。是的。好吧。这是一个备选项。
Michael says French toast.
Pam says, yes, please.
He says, what shape?
And then it says, Pam, caught off guard.
Square is fine.
Michael, where's your sense of adventure?
Pam, you're right.
Triangle it is.
迈克尔说法国吐司。帕姆说，好的，谢谢。他说，什么形状？然后写着，帕姆，措手不及。正方形的就行。迈克尔，你的冒险精神呢？帕姆，你说得对。那就三角形的。
Pause.
Michael says, how about squares?
Because that's what he can clearly make.
Pam goes, sure.
There were two more.
Michael says French toast. Pam says, yes, please. Michael says any allergies I should know about. Pam says,
shellfish. Michael says, let me wash my hands. What? Hey, my Lord. What happened? What were you
handling before I arrive? I don't want to know. Okay, Michael says French toast. Pam says,
停顿。迈克尔说，正方形的怎么样？因为那是他明显能做出来的。帕姆说，行吧。还有两个。迈克尔说法国吐司。帕姆说，好的，谢谢。迈克尔说有什么我应该知道的过敏史吗？帕姆说，贝类。迈克尔说，让我去洗个手。什么？天哪。发生了什么？在我到来之前你在碰什么？我不想知道。好的，迈克尔说法国吐司。帕姆说，
yes, please. Michael says sourdough or white. Pam says sourdough. Pam says sourdough.
Michael says,
that one's not sliced.
Pam says,
white is fine.
And then Michael,
in an exuberant French accent,
says,
好的，谢谢。迈克尔说酸面包还是白面包？帕姆说酸面包。帕姆说酸面包。迈克尔说，那个还没切片呢。帕姆说，白面包就行。然后迈克尔用夸张的法国口音说，
Toast Francie.
That's it.
Toast Francai.
Toast Francie.
But I just loved it.
And I remember we did all of those.
I was going to say,
I have memories
法式吐司。就是这样。法式吐司。法式吐司。但我就是很喜欢。而且我记得我们把那些全都演了。我是说，我有记忆
where we would get to like set things up
a little differently line by line.
And a lot of times those moments led to
the best take that was none of those.
But it like freed you up somehow, you know?
So then, if you remember, later in this episode,
Michael, Ryan, Vickram, and Pam,
they all go to see Michael's Nana at the nursing home.
我们台词一句接一句，能把事情设置得稍微有点不同。很多时候，那些时刻会带来根本不是其中任何一个的最佳镜头。但它不知怎么地解放了你，你知道吗？所以，如果你还记得的话，在这集的后面，迈克尔、瑞安、维克拉姆和帕姆，他们一起去养老院看望迈克尔的南娜。
Yeah.
And they're going to pitch Michael Scott Paper Company
to her investment group,
which is an actual group of people
who might give them money.
It was so good.
So when he gets there,
Michael goes through and he introduces all of us.
是的。他们要在那里向她的投资集团推销迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司，这是一个可能会给他们资金的真实人群。太棒了。所以当他到达那里时，迈克尔走过去把我们所有人都介绍了一遍。
and he has a way of introducing us
that kind of like makes us
sound better than we are. But here,
let's listen. I have
assembled what I believe to be
the most exciting, sought after
talent in the industry today.
Ladies and gentlemen, I present to you
他介绍我们的方式有点把我们说得比实际更好。但来吧，我们听听。我已经集成了我认为是当今行业中最令人兴奋、最炙手可热的人才。女士们先生们，我向你们呈献
the Dream Team. From our very own
Scranton, Pennsylvania,
Pam Beasley. Pretty
Pam is always reaching for
the stars and someday
she may just surprise us all and
grab one. Meet Vick.
From his humble beginnings as a standing,
梦之队。来自我们自己的宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿，帕姆·比斯利。漂亮的帕姆总是在摘星，总有一天她可能会给我们所有人一个惊喜并摘下一颗。认识一下维克。从他作为一名常驻医生的卑微起点，
from his humble beginnings as a prominent surgeon,
he risked it all to become the most successful
telemarketer in the lipophedering industry.
And do not call it a comeback.
The youngest vice president in the history
of Dunder Mifflin and recent Bowling Alley employee,
Ryan Howard is about to make a splash in paper.
in paper.
从他作为一名杰出外科医生的卑微起点，他冒着一切风险，成为了电话营销行业最成功的电话推销员。不要叫它卷土重来。邓德米弗林历史上最年轻的副总裁兼最近的保龄球馆员工，瑞安·霍华德即将在纸业掀起波澜。在纸业。
Are you about to tell me there are alts for the intros?
Only for the intros of Ryan.
Oh, come on.
Which I found so telling.
Yeah.
Because I think they just had a really good time writing alternate ways for Michael to introduce that particular character.
Yeah, yeah.
Ryan.
你该不会要告诉我介绍部分还有备选项吧？只有瑞安的介绍部分。哦，拜托。我觉得这太能说明问题了。是的。因为我觉得他们只是在为迈克尔介绍那个特定角色的不同方式时度过了一段非常快乐的时光。对，对。瑞安。
So there were 10 alts.
Oh.
I'm going to read five.
He might have said, with extensive experience in the criminal justice,
system.
Or a maverick who's used to breaking all the rules.
Nice.
He knows the world of pharmaceuticals from the inside.
所以有10个备选项。哦。我读五个。他可能说过，在刑事司法系统方面有丰富的经验。或者一个习惯打破所有规矩的独行侠。不错。他对制药界了如指掌。
I liked this one.
An outspoken advocate for justice who has argued in front of judges throughout the state.
It's a nice spin.
It's a nice spin on his court hearing.
Exactly.
And also, a man of substances who does.
doesn't know the meaning of the word quit.
So there you go.
我喜欢这个。一个直言不讳的正义倡导者，曾在全州的法官面前进行过辩护。这真是一个很好的切入点。这是对他的法庭听证会的一个很好的转折。没错。还有，一个脚踏实地且永不言弃的人。所以就是这样。
And also, while I was digging around in the candy bags, I found an episode pitch called
Michael Goes to Washington.
This is sort of the ultimate candy bag, right?
It's a whole episode pitch.
This would have been a card on the wall.
Yeah.
And I thought I could share that as well.
Let's hear it.
而且，当我在翻找糖果袋时，我发现了一个叫做《迈克尔去华盛顿》的剧集构思。这可以说是终极的糖果袋，对吧？这是一个完整的剧集构思。这本该是墙上的一张卡片。是的。我想我也可以分享这个。我们听听。
Here's what would have happened, and Michael goes to Washington.
The episode was going to start with Michael coming into the office.
He's been at the dentist, and he's holding a year-old copy of Economist magazine.
Okay.
Apparently, he read it all cover-to-cover in the waiting room, and he is now suddenly terrified about America's future.
Oh, no.
This is classic Michael.
Like he's, okay.
以下是《迈克尔去华盛顿》中将要发生的事情。这一集将从迈克尔走进办公室开始。他刚看过牙医，手里拿着一本一年前的《经济学人》杂志。好的。显然他在候诊室里把它从头到尾读了一遍，现在他突然对美国的未来感到惊恐万状。哦，不。这太经典迈克尔了。就像他，好吧。
But remember, everything he's read is one-year-old.
Right.
Nonetheless, he orders various people into the conference room to brainstorm solutions to America's problems.
I'm sorry, is that not a conference room scene that you would love to see various members of the office brainstorming America's problems?
I mean, this is the thing that Mindy has said in interviews that she would love to write Michael Scott's like take on things.
I know.
Like incredible.
So as they're doing this research, Dwight tells everybody,
但请记住，他读到的一切都是一年前的。尽管如此，他还是命令各种人去会议室为美国的各种问题头脑风暴。对不起，难道这不是你很想看到办公室的各个成员对美国的问题进行头脑风暴的会议室场景吗？我的意思是，这是明迪在采访中说过的话，她很想写迈克尔·斯科特对事情的看法。我知道。简直难以置信。所以当他们做研究时，德怀特告诉大家，
that these problems are a non-issue because the Earth will not survive the Yellowstone Supervolcano.
Side note, that is a real thing. I didn't know.
What?
The Yellowstone Supervolcano. I didn't know about it. Do you know about it?
No. I Googled it.
There's a super volcano?
There is a massive volcanic system under Yellowstone National Park.
Is that why Old Faithful blows all the time?
这些问题根本不是问题，因为地球无法在黄石超级火山爆发中存活。顺便说一句，那是真事。我不知道。什么？黄石超级火山。我不知道。你知道吗？不知道。我用谷歌查了。有一个超级火山？黄石国家公园下方有一个巨大的火山系统。这就是老忠实泉一直在喷发的原因吗？
I don't know.
But if it explodes, when it explodes, they're saying it'll explode.
Probably not in the next hundred years, but eventually it will cover most of the United States
with ash and sulfur dioxide.
What?
Yeah.
It's like an ice age event.
It's just going to like correct everything out.
我不知道。但如果它爆发，当它爆发时，他们说它会爆发。可能不是在接下来的的一百年里，但最终它会用火山灰和二氧化硫覆盖美国大部分地区。什么？是的。这就像是一场冰河世纪事件。它会把一切都重置。
Yes.
To Dwight's point, nothing will matter because we're going to go into like a decades-long volcanic winter,
Like crops will die, temperatures will plummet.
It's just something to think about.
Worry about that.
Okay, I need Michael Bay to get on this.
He needs to cast Ben Affleck.
Yeah.
是的。按照德怀特的观点，什么都不重要了，因为我们要进入长达数十年的火山冬天，庄稼会死掉，气温会骤降。这只是需要考虑的事情。担心这个。好吧，我需要迈克尔·贝来处理这件事。他需要找本·阿弗莱克来演。对。
You know, he needs to Armageddon this shit.
Yeah.
You know what?
It's an apo Armageddon.
In Armageddon, they send the oil guys, the drillers up into space.
I know.
Why don't we get a group of astronauts to dig into the volcano?
To go into the volcano.
你知道，他需要把这事搞成《绝世天劫》。对。你知道吗？这是一场末日大决战。在《绝世天劫》里，他们把石油工人、钻探工送到太空去。我知道。我们为什么不找一群宇航员去挖掘火山呢？去火山里面。
Right.
It writes it.
It does. Get someone on the phone.
Wait, do you want to watch Armageddon with me? When's the last time you saw it?
Oh my God. It's been forever ago. You want to do it?
Oh my God, Sam. Have you seen Armageddon?
Yeah, I've seen Armageddon. Like recently?
No, no, no, not since theaters.
对。剧本就是这么写的。确实如此。快给某人打电话。等等，你想跟我一起看《绝世天劫》吗？你上次看是什么时候？哦，天哪。那是好久以前了。你想看吗？哦，天哪，萨姆。你看过《绝世天劫》吗？对，我看过《绝世天劫》。最近吗？不，不，不，自从在电影院看过之后就没看过了。
Me either. I haven't seen it since I saw it in the theater. How does it that we all remember
it so well? It's clearly an amazing movie. Do we need to do it as an office ladies does Armageddon?
Yes.
Some are Blockbuster Office Ladies do Armageddon.
We'll see.
Stay tuned.
All right.
我也一样。自从我在电影院看过后就再没看过。为什么我们所有人对它的记忆都这么深刻？这显然是一部伟大的电影。我们需要把它做成“办公室女士大战绝世天劫”吗？是的。也许是“大片时代办公室女士大战绝世天劫”。我们走着瞧。我们走着瞧。敬请期待。好吧。
Back to the plot.
Michael is going to choose a team.
He's decided that their ideas are so great.
They need to get them to a representative in Washington, D.C.
So he chooses a team to go with him to deliver their findings.
He chooses Dwight and Andy.
And when they get there, and it looks like the intention was to shoot this in Washington, D.C., they get distracted.
Oh. Can you believe it? Michael wants to visit the Smithsonian because the set from MASH is there.
回到剧情。迈克尔要挑选一个团队。他决定他们的想法太棒了。他们需要把这些想法带给华盛顿特区的一位代表。所以他挑选了一个团队跟他一起去提交他们的发现。他选择了德怀特和安迪。当他们到达那里时，而且看起来他们的意图是在华盛顿特区实地拍摄，他们分心了。哦。你敢相信吗？迈克尔想去参观史密森尼学会，因为《陆军流动手术室》的布景在那里。
Dwight wants to visit the Secret Service. He also has a bone to pick with the Department of Agriculture,
and he wants to look at the back of the Declaration of Independence.
According to this document, they will eventually meet their congressmen.
Dwight has a complicated plan for breaking into the office and ambushing him, but when they
get there, it's actually not hard to get access at all. The congressman is just like wandering around
the halls, which feels to me very much like the episode where like they break in to Utica and they like
steal the whole copier. Right? It's like a very elaborate plan that didn't need to be such. Exactly. They
could just walk right in. Right. And it says the congressman is very friendly and charming,
德怀特想去参观特勤局。他对农业部也有一点意见，他想看看《独立宣言》的背面。根据这份文件，他们最终会见到他们的国会议员。德怀特有一个复杂的计划，要闯入办公室并伏击他，但当他们到达那里时，其实一点也不难进去。国会议员只是在走廊里闲逛，这让我感觉很像那一集，他们闯入尤蒂卡并偷走了整台复印机。对吧？这是一个非常精心策划的计划，其实根本没必要搞得那么复杂。没错。他们可以直接走进去。没错，上面说国会议员非常友好且迷人。
but passes them off to an aide who gives them each assigned photo and a flag pin. Oh, that's kind of
They get like a coaster or a napkin.
They're like so happy.
Exactly.
Oh, I love that so much.
Gosh, the candy bags, they don't disappoint.
They don't.
We need to do this for every character.
但把它们交给了另一位助手，助手发给每人一张指定的照片和一个国旗胸针。哦，挺那啥的，他们拿到像杯垫或餐巾纸一样的东西。他们高兴得要命。绝对是。哦，我太喜欢了。天哪，糖果袋，绝对没让人失望。确实。我们每一个角色都该来这么一次。
I agree.
Yeah.
And then we can loop back because there's more Michael Scott we didn't cover, but, you know.
Well, that's just all too much fun.
And now we have an assignment, Armageddon.
Mm-hmm.
我赞同。对。然后我们可以回过头来，因为还有更多关于迈克尔·斯科特的内容我们没聊到，不过呢。对。对。好吧，这实在是太有趣了。现在我们有了一个任务，末日降临。嗯。
I think we should take a break and come back with some around the towns.
And our office question of the week.
We are back and our first around the town comes from Lexi T and County Cork, Ireland.
Lexi wrote in and said this.
This past weekend, I completed my first proper hike in preparation for the three peaks challenge in the UK.
The challenge will aim to have the team summit the three highest peaks in the UK all within 24 hours.
In support of raising funds for cancer research in Ireland and the UK, go team.
Oh my gosh, go Lexi.
我觉得我们应该休息一下，回来后聊聊各地见闻。还有本周的办公室问答环节。我们回来了，第一个各地见闻来自爱尔兰科克郡的莱克西·T。莱克西写信说道。上周末，我完成了我人生中第一次真正的徒步，为英国的三峰挑战做准备。这项挑战旨在让团队在短短24小时内登顶英国三峰，即英国最高的3座山峰。这是为了支持爱尔兰和英国的癌症研究筹集资金，加油，团队。哦天哪，加油，莱克西。
You're going to climb three mountains in 24 hours?
I don't even understand how that's possible.
I don't either.
This is a feat.
Lexi, I have questions.
You're saying you just completed your first proper hike in preparation?
Wow.
I mean, I know people train for marathons.
你打算在24小时内爬三座山？我甚至无法理解这怎么可能。我也不懂。这真是一个壮举。莱克西，我有问题想问。你是说你为了这个刚刚完成了人生中第一次真正的徒步？哇。我的意思是，我知道有人会为马拉松进行训练。
That's right.
Well, Lexi, I want to look that up because that sounds pretty impressive and I wish you all
to luck.
I bet you're going to see some beautiful scenery as well.
Mm-hmm.
All right.
next up, Julia M from Toledo, Ohio.
Angela, I think you're going to like this.
没错。好吧，莱克西，我想查查看，因为听起来相当了不起，我祝你们一切顺利。我敢肯定你也会看到一些美丽的风景。嗯。好的，接下来是来自俄亥俄州托莱多的朱莉娅·M。安吉拉，我觉得你会喜欢这个。
Back on May 23rd this year, the Toledo Mudhens hosted a The Paper Night.
The event featured Oscar Nunez, post-game fireworks, and a can-coosy giveaway.
I knew about this because, you know, I keep up with Oscar, and I saw that he was doing it.
And I love the Toledo Mudden.
I know.
That's why I'm saying.
You've become a fan since the paper.
I've become a fan.
早在今年5月23日，托莱多泥母队举办了一场“办公室”主题之夜。活动包括奥斯卡·努涅斯的出场、赛后烟花表演以及罐套赠品。我知道这个是因为，你知道的，我有关注奥斯卡，我看到他在参加这个活动。我太喜欢托莱多泥母队了。我懂。这就是我要说的。自从《办公室》以后你成了粉丝。我成了粉丝。
So what a fun night.
All right.
Our last around the town is from Frank B.
in Lakeville, Minnesota.
Frank says, in Lakeville,
we have our own hometown celebrity,
a shirtless guy called Stickman,
who spends his days walking around town
这真是一个有趣的夜晚。好的。我们最后一个各地见闻来自明尼苏达州莱克维尔的弗兰克·B。弗兰克说，在莱克维尔，我们有自己的本地名人，一个名叫“棍子侠”的光膀子家伙，他整天在镇上走来走去
carrying a giant wooden staff.
He's half Tom Hanks and Castaway
and half Midwestern Gandalf,
and yes,
virtually everyone knows him. What started in 2007 as a local man just going out for a walk,
turned into one of the most wholesome traditions in town. He walks for hours every day,
handing out flyers, are waving at passing cards with a giant stick he found in the woods,
because apparently Minnesotans will turn literally anything into a friendly gesture. Kids get excited
手里拿着一根巨大的木棍。他一半像《荒岛余生》里的汤姆·汉克斯，另一半像中土世界的甘道夫，是的，几乎所有人都认识他。2007年开始时，只是一个当地人出门散步，后来却变成了镇上最温馨的传统之一。他每天走好几个小时，散发传单，或者用他在树林里找到的大棍子向过往的汽车挥手致意，因为显然明尼苏达州人能把任何东西变成友好的手势。孩子们看到他
when they spot him, and locals proudly explain him to confuse visitors like,
Oh, that's just stick man. We love him. Honestly, every community says they're unique,
but not every community has a mysterious wandering folk hero who spreads joy on the local streets.
Lakeville does, and we're proud of our hometown hero. I love it. I feel like I could be that.
You could be the stick lady. The stick lady? What does that look like for you?
Well, I have a giant stick, number one. Number one. And I walk around. And you walk around.
And you walk around.
And I just wave at people.
时会感到兴奋，当地人则会自豪地向感到困惑的访客解释说：“哦，那是棍子侠。我们很喜欢他。”说实话，每个社区都觉得自己是独一无二的，但并不是每个社区都有一个神秘的漫游民间英雄，在当地街道上散播欢乐。莱克维尔有，我们为我们的家乡英雄感到骄傲。我太喜欢了。我觉得我也可以成为那样的人。你可以当“棍子女士”。棍子女士？对你来说那是什么样子的？嗯，首先我得有一根大棍子。第一。然后我四处走动。然后你四处走动。然后你四处走动。然后我就向人们挥手。
And I hand out flyers about, I don't know what, anything I want.
Just friendly things.
Yeah.
That's what it sounds like.
It's like, I mean, you know I like David Sedaris.
And he just decided to clean the road by this little village he lives in outside of London.
And so he's kind of become like a little local, like, not celebrity, but kind of like, oh, he's the guy that picks up trash.
然后我散发传单，内容关于什么我不知道，任何我想发的东西。只是一些友好的事情。对。对。听起来就是这样。就像，你知道我喜欢大卫·赛德里斯。他只是决定清理他住在伦敦郊外那个小村庄旁边的道路。所以他有点像成了一个当地的小人物，倒算不上名人，而是那种“哦，就是那个捡垃圾的家伙”。
Yeah.
And he does it every day.
I mean, people must be so happy.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
I could do that too.
Plus, who doesn't love a great stick?
对。而且他每天都这么做。人们一定太高兴了。嗯。对。我也能做到这一点。对，另外，谁会不喜欢一根好棍子呢？
Who doesn't?
I mean, how many hours did you spend with your kids on walks and they'd get so excited if they found a good stick?
You know what we found in our garage when we cleaned it out?
Okay, this is crazy.
Talk about a giant stick.
Way up high, almost by the ceiling of the garage.
Okay.
Because we had to clear out the whole garage.
谁会不喜欢呢？我的意思是，你和孩子们散步时花了多少小时，如果他们找到一根好棍子就会兴奋得不得了？你知道我们在车库大扫除时发现了什么吗？好吧，这太疯狂了。说到一根大棍子。高高在上，几乎挨着车库天花板。好吧。因为我们得把整个车库清空。
because we took everything out, we put it all back in.
Shelds and all that.
All that stuff.
Yeah.
On a couple of nails, I don't know how long this thing has been there.
Like old rusted nails.
Mm-hmm.
Like perched on these nails was the longest, like the length of the whole wall piece of like a bamboo stick.
因为我们把所有东西都拿出来了，然后又全部放回去。架子之类的一切。所有那些东西。Yeah。挂在几个钉子上，我不知道这东西在那里放了多久。就像生锈的老钉子。嗯。就搭在这些钉子上的是一件长得像整面墙那么长的东西，像是一根竹竿。
Like a bamboo stick.
And Lee and I were like, what?
Like why?
Like someone cared enough to put these nails here and put this up here.
Yeah, that bamboo stick was important to them.
For what reason?
We couldn't figure out what it was.
So then, a few days passed, Lee comes up to me.
就像一根竹竿。莉和我当时都惊了，什么？为什么？就像有人特意把这些钉子钉在这儿，然后把这东西放上去一样。对，那根竹竿对他们来说很重要。出于什么原因？我们弄不懂它是用来干嘛的。然后，过了几天，莉走到我跟前。
He says, I think I know what it's for.
What?
I'm like, what is it for?
And he said that we'd had a rain.
and our gutters were full of leaves.
And so the rainwater was like dripping down by the window on the house.
You know, the gutter was full.
Yeah.
他说，我想我知道它是干什么用的。什么？我说，它是干什么用的？他说我们刚经历了一场雨。我们的排水沟里落满了树叶。所以雨水就顺着房子旁边的窗户往下淌。你知道的，排水沟满了。对。
He said, I got up on a ladder.
And I thought, I need something I can poke these leaves out with.
I just need something to get these leaves out of the gutter.
And I remembered the stick.
I remembered the bamboo stick.
And he said, Jenna, I got it.
And it was exactly the length.
of the gutter, and it was like pliable and it wasn't too heavy, but it was also firm enough.
他说，我爬上梯子。我想，我需要找个东西把这些树叶捅出来。我只需要找个东西把排水沟里的树叶弄出来。然后我想起了那根棍子。我想起了那根竹竿。他说，珍娜，我找到了。它刚好和排水沟一样长，而且它很有韧性，不是特别重，但同时也足够结实。
And he cleared our gutters. He goes, I think that man used it to clear the gutters. He's convinced.
We kept it. We put it back up on the nails. I was going to say, that is part of your home now.
Yeah. Done. Giant stick. Giant stick. What a find. I mean, I love stuff like that.
Yeah. Clearly, Frank from Minnesota, we got very, very.
excited about your stick man story.
Our office question in the week comes from Sarah L in Arlington, Virginia, who said, if you ladies
were going to do one other job on the set of the office, which job would you want to do and why?
This is very interesting to Sarah, because there's the job or jobs that I think I would be good at,
然后他清理了我们的排水沟。他说，我猜那个男人就是用它来清理排水沟的。他深信不疑。我们把它留下了。我们把它重新挂回钉子上了。我本来想说，那是你家的一部分了。对。搞定。大棍子。大棍子。真是个大发现。我的意思是，我就喜欢这种东西。对。显然，来自明尼苏达州的弗兰克，我们对你的棍子侠的故事感到非常非常兴奋。本周的办公室问答来自弗吉尼亚州阿灵顿的莎拉·L，她说，如果你们这些女士要在《办公室》剧组做另一份工作，你们会想做什么工作，为什么？这对莎拉来说非常有趣，因为有些工作我认为我能胜任，
but I don't want them.
And then there's the job I would want, but I don't think I'd be good.
Well, I know what you'd be good at, and that'd be like our line producer.
Yeah.
You'd be very good.
You would know our budget.
You would know what we could spend.
You would know, like, all the things to make us stay on schedule.
但我并不想做。还有一些工作我想做，但我认为我做不好。好吧，我知道你擅长什么，比如我们的制片主任。对。你会非常出色。你会了解我们的预算。你会知道我们能花多少钱。你会知道所有能让我们按计划进行的事情。
Mm-hmm.
So that you'd be very good at.
Can I try to guess what you'd want to do, but you don't think you'd be good at?
Sure.
I won't be offended.
Like, this could get dicey quick.
Well, I was thinking, like, maybe, like,
what am I not good at is basically the question that you're pondering.
嗯。所以你在这方面会非常擅长。我能猜猜你想做什么，但又觉得自己做不好的工作吗？当然。我不会生气的。这可能很快就会变得棘手。嗯，我在想，也许，基本上我擅长什么不是你正在琢磨的问题。
I was like going to say like, I mean, the hair and makeup trailers are a really fun place to be.
What are you saying?
What are you saying about my hair and makeup skills?
I am saying I think you put yourself together very well, but we have both sort of bonded over the years and the fact that we don't wear a lot of makeup and we don't do much with our hair.
Look at us today.
Look at us.
Okay, fair enough. That wasn't what I was thinking. Is there anything else you think I'm not good at?
Yeah, I'll keep going. What about like the construction?
我本来想说，我是说，发型和化妆车真是一个非常有趣的地方。你在说什么？你对我的发型和化妆技术有什么意见？我想说的是，我觉得你把自己收拾得很好，但这些年来我们都有过这样的共鸣，那就是我们不怎么化妆，也不怎么弄头发。看看我们今天。看看我们好吧，好吧。这不是我想的那样。你还觉得我有什么不擅长的吗？好吧，我继续说。那建筑工作怎么样？
Oh my gosh. No, that also was not my answer. Okay, I'm done. What? Directing. Oh, you'd be great at directing. That's why I didn't even guess that. I disagree with your internal monologue. You'd be a great director.
I, so I don't think so. I think directors, they have to be able to look at things from the outside.
Yeah. And like create, they have to paint a whole picture. Yes. And I don't think, I just don't, that's not how my brain works. Like, I'm all character, you know, and from the inside out. And so I just don't think I would know where to like point the camera or tell people to stand. Like I don't see it that way when I read it. But I would love.
to be a director because then I would be on set and I'd be in the creative process, but I will not
have ever gone through hair and makeup. I wouldn't have to wear clothes that are uncomfortable.
Exactly. So that would be my choice of my dream job. I love directing. You know, it's been a long
time, but I had directed some theater and stuff in college. And the only thing for me is because
I do like a big picture, I get really impatient. If like there was this one gal who,
哦，天哪。不，那也不是我的答案。好吧，我放弃。什么？导演。哦，你很适合当导演。这就是为什么我根本没猜到那个。我不同意你内心的独白。你会是个好导演。我，嗯，我不这么觉得。我觉得导演必须能够从外部看待事物。是的。并且要像创作一样，他们必须描绘出一幅完整的画面。是的。我不觉得，我只是不觉得，我的大脑不是那样运作的。比如，我完全是关于角色的，你知道的，从内到外的。所以我觉得我不会知道该把镜头指向哪里，或者告诉人们站在哪里。当我阅读剧本时，我并不是那样看待它的。但我很乐意。去当导演，因为那样我就可以在片场，参与到创作过程中，但我永远不需要经历发型和化妆。我也不用穿不舒服的衣服。没错。所以那会是我梦想中的工作。我热爱导演。你知道，这已经是很久以前的事了，但我在大学时导演过一些戏剧之类的东西。唯一让我觉得的是，因为我确实喜欢大局，我会变得非常不耐烦。如果像有那么一个姑娘，
who just was not getting the note for this performance note that I had.
And I just need to just be like, she's just going to do it her way.
She can't, like, process any kind of change.
And but I think I was a little, I think I maybe was a little short.
Well, this is another thing about directing, which is that you get asked so many questions all day.
I don't have the temperament for that.
Yeah.
So in that way, I don't think I think.
她就是无法理解我对这次表演提出的意见。我只需要对自己说，她只是会按她自己的方式去做。她无法处理任何形式的改变。但我认为我有点，我想我当时可能有点急躁。好吧，这也是关于导演的另一件事，那就是你整天会被问到无数的问题。我没有那种性情。是的。所以从这个意义上说，我不认为我觉得。
It's your wedding day every single day.
Yes.
Yes. Do you want this color cranberry or that color cranberry?
And then you have someone come up to you who's just like, you're in the middle of something and they're like, there's no toilet paper in the bathroom. And you're like, what? What am I? I'm the bride. I'm not in charge of toilet paper today. Yeah. But just people just come up and say all kinds of stuff. Do you have to solve every problem all day long? Yeah. And you have to be nice and patient.
So what would you want to do, lady? Should I say the things I think you shouldn't do?
Yeah.
No, I'm kidding.
Yes, you should.
这就像你每天都在过婚礼一样。是的。是的。你想用这个蔓越莓色还是那个蔓越莓色？然后会有人走到你面前，就在你正忙的时候，他们对你说，洗手间里没有厕纸了。然后你会说，什么？我是什么人？我是新娘。我今天不负责厕纸。是的。但人们就是会走过来跟你说各种各样的话。你得一整天都在解决所有问题吗？是的。而且你必须保持和蔼和耐心。那么，你想做什么呢，女士？我是不是该说那些我认为你不该做的事？好吧。不，开玩笑的。是的，你应该。
You should.
I'm kidding.
I don't think you should run catering.
I don't.
What?
I threw great parties.
Crafty.
You can be in charge of crafty.
你应该。开玩笑的。我觉得你不应该负责餐饮。我不觉得。什么？我办过很好的派对。剧组后勤。你可以负责剧组后勤。
Snacks.
I could be in charge of snacks.
A hundred percent.
100 percent.
I don't want you to cook the meals.
You probably don't want me to.
You know what?
I'm good at like one dish at a time.
零食。我可以负责零食。百分之百。百分之百。我可不想让你做饭。你可能也不想让我做。你知道吗？我擅长一次做好一道菜。
I know.
I am not a short order chef.
No. I can't do that. But also, you have a very limited number of meals that you cook well.
It's true. And you cook them well. I cook them well. Josh is amazing. I'm going to be eating the same thing all the time. You are. If you're in church catering. Yeah. But snacks I would actually very much enjoy being crafty on set. Because then I could figure out what people's favorite snacks are. And it's like a love language to take care of you. I could make sure you had your favorite jelly beans or. You'd be great at crafty. I would love being, I would love being crafty. Yeah. Yeah.
The other one that I thought would be fun would be to be a gaffer.
I love light.
I love seeing how light changes a scene.
Oh, okay.
我知道。我不是那种能随叫随到、瞬间做好几道菜的大厨。不。我做不到。而且，你擅长做的饭菜数量非常有限。确实如此。而且你做得很棒。我做得很棒。乔许太棒了。我得一直吃同样的东西了。确实。如果你负责餐饮的话。是的。不过对于零食，我其实会非常乐意在片场负责剧组后勤。因为那样我就可以弄清楚大家最喜欢吃什么零食。照顾你们就像是一种爱的语言。我可以确保你们有最喜欢的果冻豆或者。你很适合做后勤。我会很喜欢，我会很乐意负责后勤。是的。是的。另一个我觉得会很有趣的工作是成为一名灯光师。我热爱光。我喜欢看光是如何改变一个场景的。哦，好吧。
Yeah, I mean, it's a super cool, like, artistic job.
Like, if there's a faky window, you have to make me believe that's a real window using light.
I know.
And you know what else I think is so cool?
And we only did this a handful of times on the set of the office, but I've done it on movies
plenty of times where you're filming in its broad daylight, but they're.
They make everything to look like nighttime.
Day for night.
是的，我的意思是，这是一份超级酷的、具有艺术性的工作。比如，如果有一个假窗户，你必须用光让我相信那是一扇真正的窗户。我懂。你知道我还觉得什么特别酷吗？我们在办公室剧组只做过几次，但我在很多电影里都做过，就是在光天化日之下拍摄，但他们。他们把一切都弄得像是在夜里。日戏夜拍。
They call it day for night.
Yeah, and they black out the windows.
But then they'll let a little light through like it's moonlight.
But you step outside and it's three o'clock in the afternoon.
Yeah.
It's so cool.
I couldn't do that job.
Lighting is really cool.
他们管这叫日戏夜拍。是的，他们把窗户用黑布封起来。但随后他们会让一点光透进来，就像是月光一样。但你走到外面去，其实才下午三点。太酷了。我可干不了那份工作。灯光真的很酷。
Yeah.
I don't know if I'd be good at it, but I really appreciate it.
Those are good answers.
Yeah.
So basically, if I wasn't acting, you think I'd be in charge of crafty.
是的。我不知道我是否擅长，但我真的很欣赏它。是的。这些都是好答案。是的。所以基本上，如果我不演戏，你觉得我会负责剧组后勤。是的。是的。
And I would love to be directing, but I'm not sure it would be my strong suit.
So I might be line producing.
I might be your AD.
I think I'd be good at it.
Oh, yeah.
You'd be a great AD.
The scheduling.
Mm-hmm.
而我会很想当导演，但我不太确定这会是我的强项。所以我可能会去当制片主任。我可能会当你的副导演。我觉得我能干好。哦，是的。你会是个出色的副导演。负责排期。嗯——哼。
Yeah.
I think I would like it.
And if I were first AD, I'd get to be on set and I'd get to be around all the funny stuff.
And I'd be on set as crafty.
I'd be right outside the door there, but on stage.
Crafty is a lot of times on the stage.
And it's just sort of behind like the main.
like the main structures that you're filming in.
是的。我觉得我会喜欢它。如果我是第一副导演，我就能去片场，就能接触到所有有趣的事情。我会作为后勤人员留在片场。我就在门外，但在舞台上。剧组后勤很多时候都在舞台上。它只是隐身在那些你正在拍摄的主要结构后面。
So you kind of have to be quiet over there
because, you know, you've got your snacks.
But you see all the actors and the crew.
Well, if I were second AD,
then I would be back there with you.
Yeah.
And then we would be best friends again.
所以你在那里得保持安静，因为，你知道的，你带着零食。但你能看到所有的演员和工作人员。好吧，如果我是第二副导演，那我就能和你待在后面了。是的。然后我们就又是好朋友了。是的。
Okay, so you're crafty and I'm second AD.
Done.
All right.
Thank you for sending in all of your tidbits.
Thank you for your letters.
Oh, wait, Sam, did you take your test?
I did.
I am.
好吧，所以你负责后勤，我是第二副导演。就这么定了。好的。谢谢你们发来所有的趣闻轶事。谢谢你们的来信。哦，等等，山姆，你做测试了吗？做了。我是。
What are you?
Type 1, the reformer.
Type 1, the reformer me.
Yeah.
We're the same.
Look at us.
Mm-hmm.
你是什么型？1号，改革者。1号，我也是改革者。我们是一样的。看我们。嗯——哼。
I'm 95% the reformer, 89% the investigator.
Oh.
89% the challenger.
Okay.
What are you the least?
I am the least, the loyalist.
The loyalist.
Oh, that's weird.
我是95%的改革者，89%的调查者。哦。89%的挑战者。好吧。你得分最低的是什么？我最低的是，忠诚者。忠诚者。哦，这真奇怪。
Yeah.
Huh.
I mean, I don't know if it's super literal, but I find you to be very loyal.
Yeah, me too.
Well, huh.
Not according to this quiz.
Again, I don't know what you said on this quiz. Yeah, exactly.
Well, you probably like didn't strongly disagree enough.
是的。哈。我的意思是，我不知道这是否非常字面化，但我发现你非常忠诚。是的，我也是。好吧，哈。根据这个测验可不是这样。再说一次，我不知道你在测验里选了什么。是的，确实。好吧，你可能就是没有给出足够强烈的“不同意”吧。
Yeah, a lot of these questions are what bother me about astrology, where it's like the questions are so generic they could apply to anybody.
But then all of a sudden you're a reformer.
Yeah, exactly.
Matt Beagle, did you take it by any chance?
You know, I did. And I also got the reformer, which feels wrong.
What is this test? The test is the reformer.
The second one I got is the peacemaker, which I feel like I identify more with.
Okay.
是的，这些问题里有很多正是让我对占星术感到困惑的地方，因为问题太笼统了，可以套用在任何人身上。但突然之间你成了改革者。是的，完全如此。马特·比格尔，你碰巧做了吗？你知道吗，我做了。而且我也测出是改革者，这感觉不太对。这到底是什么测试？这个测试是改革者。我测出的第二个结果是和平缔造者，我觉得我跟这个更有共鸣。好吧。
So we have...
Do we have a good balance?
We have two reformers, one reformer slash peacemaker, one helper slash challenger.
Is that a good way to make a podcast?
It's working.
Well, I think it's a pretty good way to make a podcast because y'all, this is our 300th episode.
Woo-hoo!
How's about that?
所以我们有……我们有一个好的平衡吗？我们有两个改革者，一个改革者兼和平缔造者，一个助人者兼挑战者。这是制作播客的好方法吗？效果不错。嗯，我觉得这是制作播客相当不错的方法，因为各位，这是我们的第300期节目。呜呼！感觉怎么样？
300 episodes.
Yeah.
Over 500 and 1 million downloads.
Hey. I know. Really, I should write music. Why don't we write jingles? We should. Well, listen, thank you to everyone who wrote in. We had a great time with this episode and we'll see you next week. See you then. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle and our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill.
Shultz. Our theme song is
Ruppertry by Creed Bratton.
Spotify, it's Jay Shetty.
Are you one of those media strategy
300期节目。是的。超过5亿和100万次的下载量。嘿。我知道。真的，我应该写音乐。我们为什么不写广告歌呢？我们应该的。好吧，听着，谢谢所有写信给我们的朋友。我们这期节目过得很开心，我们下周见。回头见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是Audyssey呈献的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的资深制作人是马特·比格尔，我们的音频工程师是山姆·基弗。Audyssey的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由比尔·舒尔茨进行混音和母带制作。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《Ruppertry》。Spotify，我是杰·谢蒂。你也是那种媒体策略
people? Scrolling through spreadsheets,
searching for an audience that pays
twice as much attention to your ads
than they do on social?
Let me introduce you to fans.
And they're here with me on Spotify.
Trust me, I know fans.
They don't skip, they stay for hours.
人员吗？在电子表格中滚动，寻找那些对你的广告的关注度是社交媒体上两倍的目标受众？让我为你介绍粉丝。他们和我一起在Spotify上。相信我，我知道什么是粉丝。他们从不跳过，他们会停留好几个小时。
They don't move on, they manifest.
They're not a demographic group.
They're fans.
Spotify advertising.
You're among fans.
他们不会离开，他们就在这里展现。他们不是一个人口统计群体。他们是粉丝。Spotify广告。你在粉丝之中。